- All right, here's a theory
I've been thinking about.
Someday, maybe not next year
or five or even 10 years,
but maybe someday we'll
all live in a world
where we all have these wearable computers
on our faces all the time.
And a lot of these tech companies
really believe in that future.
Like I've never spoken
to anyone on Planet Earth
who believes more than Mark Zuckerberg
that humans are on their way to spending
tons of their time in
some sort of metaverse.
But the tech is clearly
not good enough yet,
today in 2023 for anyone to wanna do that.
Like this is what a VR
headset looks like in 2023,
and this is the best we've got.
And even now, the computers
and pixels and batteries,
and everything on your face are too much
for people to wanna spend all
day in something like this.
But we're all kind of on board that
maybe someday the tech will
shrink down more, and more,
and more and more until eventually,
it's no more than just a
normal looking pair of glasses.
And then maybe at that point,
we'll all be cool wearing it every day.
So this is Quest 3,
this newest and latest and
greatest headset from Meta.
My theory is, is on
this side of the scale,
and on the other side of the
sliding scale is smart glasses.
And meta literally is also
announcing smart glasses
at their event.
So these things are
literally called the RayBan
Meta Smart Glasses, AKA
the RayBan Stories too.
Right now, they are super simple,
they don't do much
because they can only fit
a camera and small
speakers, and a battery,
but there are some clever tricks
that enable them to do
as much as possible.
And maybe someday the tech
will get powerful enough
and useful enough for people
to want to use these every day.
So VR headsets are racing
to get smaller and smaller,
and smart glasses are racing
to get better and better tech,
and they're both basically
racing towards each other,
and companies like Meta are
spending tons and tons of money
to develop these things to figure out
which strategy will hit first.
So let's see.
Let's start with the headset.
So this is the latest and
greatest from Meta, the Quest 3.
And this is the year they made
their big pivot to it being
a mixed reality headset,
which in hindsight feels
like a natural progression
for these things if you wanna
get them more comfortable
for people to wear every day like glasses.
So in previous VR headsets,
it really felt like pass
through was an afterthought.
Like you put the headset on,
and you're just immediately
in your own world
until you take the headset off.
And this new version is
still built to be immersive,
it still has all the light blocking
and fills your field of view with screens
and makes it as immersive as possible.
But it now has a bunch more sensors
arranged around the outside
that make pass through
dramatically better than before.
It's now color, stereo, very low latency,
and decently high resolution.
And there's immediately
a bunch of benefits
to having pass through being this good.
First of all, the setup
was way more intuitive.
Like you can literally
take it to a new spot
for the first time and
just put it on it boots up,
and automatically you look down
and it just maps out the
floor of the room you're in.
The available floor space,
the objects in the room,
the spots where you can stand,
and to surprisingly great accuracy.
So it's using a pair of RGB cameras
and the Lidar sensor in the middle.
So you no longer have to
painstakingly draw a play area
every single time and stick with it.
It just naturally feels
like it plants the menu
floating right in the middle
of where you're standing,
and you can still see
everything around you.
Now you may be wondering,
okay, how good though
like exactly is the Quest 3?
Is it the best?
Is it better than the Quest Pro?
Yes, it's better than the Quest Pro
but it is not as good as Apple Vision Pro.
I would kind of equate it to like,
if I gave you a clear pair of glasses
that were not exactly your prescription.
But basically this one's good
because it's stereo and color,
and nearly real time, so
you see accurate colors,
you look at your hands and
you can find the controllers
wherever they are in the room,
just pick them up and put them down
without needing someone
to hand them to you.
Just so many benefits like that.
There's also just a small
amount of distortion
with up close objects
and things near the edges of your vision.
But it's not quite high
enough fidelity to like
pick up your phone and
start using that screen.
So like if you get a text,
you're still gonna have
to take the headset off
to be able to read it.
And I know comparing
it to a $3,500 headset
feels unnecessary and it kind of is,
but also a lot of people
are asking me about it,
and I'm one of the few
people who can actually
say they've tried both.
So I will say that yes, Apple Vision Pro
is still the best pass
through I've ever experienced.
I distinctly remember taking
notes about my experience
on my phone while still
wearing the headset,
it was kind of insane.
But for a $500 headset, yeah.
This is absolutely as
good as you're gonna see.
And combined with the high
resolution of the actual menus
and the accuracy of the controllers,
I think it's pretty awesome.
And then of course, the
other benefit to having
way higher quality sensors
around the outside of the headset
is you don't actually
need the controllers.
Now you've always had the choice
to either use the controllers
or use your hands.
And these controllers have
gotten better over the years,
they're smaller, they're pretty sweet,
they have better haptics than ever before.
But the hand tracking has
also gotten way better
and really intuitive and responsive.
And I think this is key again,
to feeling like the future.
So you do this pinch gesture
here to pull up the menu
and move around to select things.
You can literally scroll around menus
by touching the digital menu
and flinging them through
space with your finger.
Or you can grab a window
and just move it around,
putting it on a table or
floating it in the air,
and it just stays locked
there, which is pretty awesome.
So pretty much everything
except typing is natural.
It works as you'd expect,
like you're typing on a virtual
keyboard floating in space,
but this will definitely
take more practice,
because there's no haptic feedback.
See the other gestures I was talking about
almost always have a haptic feedback
of your own fingers hitting each other,
which is really interesting.
This keyboard here,
you're sort of just poking
an invisible plane in the air
where the keyboard should be,
so that that's a little tougher.
The main selling point
of this headset though,
is still playing games, that's
still what it's super good at
and it plays all the same games
that the Quest 2 could play,
and there are even some
games optimized for Quest 3
that it's even better at.
It has this nextgen Qualcomm
Snapdragon XR2 chip,
it has higher resolution per eye,
it has a wider more
immersive field of view,
and it's, in my opinion
slightly more comfortable,
thanks to this new strap that
improves weight distribution.
So I've been playing a bunch,
I've really enjoyed this
golf game that feels
surprisingly realistic as
someone that was expecting like
wee golf levels of graphics and control.
Also pinging pong,
which this has this eerie
multiplayer mode online,
where someone else's avatar
just shows up in your space
standing 10 feet away from
you, but with no legs.
But there's the classics
like Beat Saber, Super Hot,
and then even some new ones
like The Rotag is Blowing Up.
All this stuff is the
main reason why today,
you'd buy something like this,
to spend like half an hour in the thing.
But again, the tech is shrinking down
more and more and more,
and will every single year,
until it gets close to something
like these, smart glasses.
So let's talk about the smart glasses.
So these are the Meta Smart Glasses,
and there's others like it,
but they're gonna start at
the other end of the spectrum
where there's only so much stuff
that you can stuff into a
regular looking pair of glasses
that nobody would even look twice at.
But over time, as tech gets
better and more powerful,
and more miniaturized,
these things will get
more and more powerful
and more and more able to do more stuff.
So right now this is a 12 megapixel camera
with a little LED light ring
to indicate when it's recording
or taking a picture.
A shutter button on top, and
then a literal computer inside
with some storage, a
touch pad on the side,
and then some microphones,
and then these really
tiny pinhole speakers
that fire audio downwards
directly into your ears.
It doesn't sound like much,
but when paired directly to your phone,
and the Meta View app, this
thing is surprisingly capable
as a little computer on your face.
So you can use the camera of course
to just take first person
pictures and videos
just by hitting the shutter button.
Videos are limited to 60 seconds or less,
and portrait orientation.
But honestly, despite all that,
they're actually pretty
solid looking videos
and there's some promise here,
I kind of feel like I might
want to use these for auto focus
for like car driving footage,
if I could get wide screen out of them,
that would be awesome.
And then you can also start a recording
or take a picture just by saying,
"Hey, Meta take a picture."
And so you could see
that it was pretty fast,
the little light there.
I don't know if you wanna
say that phrase out loud very often,
so you might just stick to one of these,
but yeah, it has a voice
assistant built in.
So you can send and receive messages
through WhatsApp Messenger,
you know, Meta stuff.
But it's just audio,
like there's no screen
anywhere in here built in.
So this really works best with experiences
that can be entirely
handled with just audio.
So they're connected all
the time to your phone
via Bluetooth, so you can listen to music.
And these little speakers
are directional enough that
at half volume, there's
really not that much bleed.
And that high volume, it
kind of just sounds the same
as someone like maybe
listening next to you
with open back headphones.
(rap music)
That's as loud as it gets.
But you can also ask questions of the Meta
virtual assistant, little
AI virtual assistant
built into the computers in
this little pair of glasses.
And you have to ask it,
"Hey Meta, what's the weather tomorrow?"
And then it reads the answers
directly into your ears.
And so now I know it's gonna rain
for our last parts of the year, great.
We can also ask it random
questions about people.
I asked it to write a poem
and it gave me a poem.
It's internet connected from your phone,
so it can do a bunch of stuff.
For fun, I asked it to write
an acceptance speech for me
as I walk onto stage
wearing the sunglasses.
And by the time I got on stage
I can start saying an acceptance speech
as it's reading them into my ears,
which I thought was,
that's kind of a fun hack.
So this is all based on Meta's
new Llama 2 language model.
So it's pretty fluid and you
don't have to rely on saying
certain specific phrases to get it to
keep going through the conversation.
Now you know, it's not
the best AI assistant
I've ever heard, and it
still has its limitations,
it still can't set alarms,
or access third party
services that aren't Meta.
But the fact that I could
be on a phone call right now
and you wouldn't even notice in public,
that's kind of the point.
There's two different
styles by RayBan for these.
These are the headliner and the Wayfarer.
The downside is very clearly battery life.
I mean, this is a small,
small battery to fit in here.
So it's cool that you have
this wireless charging case.
So the second you take them off,
you can just put them in the case,
and charge them back up,
just like earbuds basically.
So it's more about how many times
the case can charge them up.
Honestly, on one charge, if
I listen to a bunch of music
and take a bunch of pictures and videos,
I can kill these things
in under two hours.
But they're quoting 36
total hours of battery life
with the charging case.
By the way, the recording
light is on one side,
but then it's the camera
on the other side.
So that keeps it nice and symmetrical
like normal glasses should be.
But that's the idea, this
is about as much tech
as you can fit in a normal
looking pair of glasses in 2023
without it starting to look weird
with the current tech we have,
but it's gonna be more
and more and more stuff,
and still looking like this every year.
So the question is,
which side would you bet
gets mass adoption first?
And this is a question tech
companies have to answer
before they start investing.
Now Meta is invested in both.
So maybe they win either
way and they're involved.
But if you're Snapchat,
they've already tried,
just the smart glasses,
and maybe they'll keep doing that later.
If you're Apple, they've
clearly started with
Apple Vision Pro, and they're
gonna try to miniaturize that
and shrink that year after year.
But which side?
And what a time to be
alive for all of this!
'Cause the tech that we're
gonna have on our faces
in 10, 20 years is gonna look insane
compared to what we have today.
The same way that the
tech we had 10 years ago
looks archaic compared
to what we have now.
So all that being said,
I'll leave you with this;
One, Quest 3 for 500 bucks is awesome,
and if you're looking to get a VR headset
or a mixed reality headset at all,
no problem recommending
this one, it's pretty sweet.
Two, Apple's Vision Pro is still on track
to be released early 2024,
and I think it's gonna be pretty awesome.
So make sure you get subscribed
to see the review of that when it happens.
And three, I'm pretty
sure we are barreling
towards this computer's
on our faces future.
At some point it does
feel like it's picking up
that much steam and that much investment.
So even if you don't believe
we're all gonna be
wearing these on our faces
for a super long time, it
probably won't be this,
it'll be something smaller,
and slowly we'll get more
and more base computer time.
So which side do you pick?
Thanks for watching.
Catch you on the next one.
Peace.
(upbeat music)